a scary night for a blind therapy dog
after somebody broke into dog junkies
that's a thrift store that works closely
with a home for spot
this incident was caught on camera 8
news now reporter madison kimbrough
shows us what happened inside
they had to lift up the gate and then
bust it open
and then they went in and grabbed a
bunch of stuff an unsettling night for a
place that does a lot of good for
animals and people in need
dog junkies thrift store which is a part
of the nonprofit organization a home for
spot
animal rescue was burglarized here's
footage from wednesday night
not only did the three men steal from
the shop they left the gate open and a
blind foster dog got out
rebecca anderson recalls the owner diana
coming in the next morning to find
thor gone she walked around made sure
that he wasn't in
you know somewhere hiding out or hanging
out and she panicked
and that's when she called me
immediately and asked me to look on the
cameras
thursday a good samaritan called and
thor was in their pool
struggling to stay afloat he had
actually traveled
northbound on decatur crossed over
that busy craig and decatur and then
continued to go
back behind the albersons over there
into a large community
and he the guy was having work done on
his brick wall
so that's why he was able to get into
his backyard
as for what was stolen it was mostly
clothes and household goods that were to
be donated
they knew exactly where to go they knew
what to look for they knew the cameras
were there
for now dog junkies thrift store is
increasing their security
and they hope the thieves are caught
reporting in north las vegas madison
kimbrough 8 news now